[Music]
sonny is with us in dallas texas hi
sonny welcome to the ramsey show how can
we help
hey guys how y'all doing today thank you
for taking my call um i'm just real
brief i'm 27 years old my wife is 27 as
well we have three kids that are all
under the age of five
um we're just we're stuck i mean living
paycheck to paycheck
i work in the oil field and
luckily now i'm in the position where
they're trying to train me up to a
higher position with better pay
my wife is a uh she just took a job uh
being a christian principal at a
christian school
um what do you guys remember like a
pretty significant pay cut
no more than probably about 60 70 000 a
year
that was pretty vague you don't know
what you make
uh i mean from working in the oil field
out here it it
it fluctuates quite a very nice
if you have money problems
the church the church is real small and
the christian academy that she became
the principal at is very small as well
she's working to get more students in
why did she take a pay cut
why did she take a job
when you all are broke that was a pay
cut
from our discussion she said it felt
like it was god's calling
i mean we're very strong in our faith
and
i mean anytime god calls on us i mean
we we jump to it what was she doing
before she moved into this role
she was a assistant director at the boys
and girls club
making about 20 000 here and now she's
making less than 20 000.
she makes about 600 every two weeks
take home about 550 after taxes
well
does she feel called into education or
christian education specifically
christian education
well i want to challenge an assumption
here that that's the only way she can do
that i certainly understand the passion
here
uh but but but this has financial
implications to it so listen we're both
strong in our faith too and we believe
god calls you things just like you guys
do yeah but let me tell you what
he also says you need to take care of
your own household first or you're worse
than an unbeliever he doesn't call you
to do things that are perpendicular to
scripture
yes sir and so i'm i'm i'm gonna
challenge that straight up i mean i'm
not saying she needs to go quit her job
but you can't just throw the god card
down on something that mathematically
doesn't work and that all of a sudden
makes it work
um yes sir sometimes sometimes god tells
us to do that i'm i'm open to that idea
but that's the exception rather than the
rule
in the way that he interacts with us um
and that's me walking with him for 50
years so uh anyway all right so now you
guys have got a 60 70 000 income and
you're living paycheck to paycheck and
you're sick of that and you're getting a
raise you think on the oil field
yes sir how much your raise gonna be
uh
i could i'm right now i'm making 20 an
hour and i could be jumping up to
anywhere from 75 to 85 000 a year i'll
be put on salary well that'd make a lot
of difference
yes it would because i put you guys at
100k instead of 70k
yes sir yeehaw okay so how much debt do
you have how much debt do you have sonny
um combined with the vehicle it's
probably about maybe 30 000. and with
the vehicle how much is the vehicle debt
uh about
17 18k okay all right
well what we'll do is i'm going to put
you guys into uh financial peace
university in ramsey plus okay
i want you to go through the class do
what
i said thank you sir sure we're gonna
pay for it cause i've been broke and and
scared and not knowing what to do just
like you guys are i know how it feels
so i want you guys to get in there and
get on the written budget on the every
dollar app and both of you working
together on that app i want you to
attack this debt with every dollar you
can squeeze out of your life no eating
out no vacations you're broke people
you got to get out of not being broke
people before you start goofing off with
money again and we're going to get you
out because it's not a forever thing and
it doesn't necessarily depend on your
raise but your raise will help
yes sir okay so we're not going out to
eat we're not going on vacations and if
you can't turn the corner pretty quick
on doing the budget and start actually
making some progress paying off some of
your smaller debts you may need to sell
that car i don't think you do though
i think you guys getting in control and
working together and sacrificing and
having a written plan which will make
you feel like you've got a raise
i think you can turn the corner with
what you got without selling the car but
if you have to sell the car to get where
you can balance this out
her job pay cut may have cost you the
car
yes sir it may mean you can't afford it
i don't think so though i think you can
make it
and i want you guys to slow down um
and look at the total picture of your
life
when god starts calling you to something
and and is he calling you to a specific
thing like that particular school or is
he calling you to christian ed instead
of boys or girls club or is he calling
you to help out over at the church where
you go that's a small church and really
can't afford a principal
because they're not paying a principal
enough to stay above the poverty level
so maybe they need to have a lay person
that's a volunteer and your wife does
this as her volunteer ministry on the
side while she keeps her other job or a
different job that that's another way
you guys could have gotten at fulfilling
that same burden that the holy spirit
was putting on her and i'm not doubting
that that god spoke to you guys about
this i'm just doubting the way it's
played out in the timing of it uh
because it's left you guys in a lurch
and my heavenly father is crazy about me
and he doesn't lead me into a canyon to
get killed
yeah i i think there's a couple things i
would look at seasons
if she were she's got a commitment now
so if there's two or three months left
in the school year i don't know what it
is in texas but she can fulfill her
commitment but also find a christian
education job that pays
way more than what she's getting which i
think is about 1200 a month which will
help you all and then there may be a
season of life where she does work for
way less as a true ministry but that may
be a season much further down the road i
think you gotta really discern and
really look into that situation i i you
know be careful how you bring it up to
her you want to honor her heart but also
go hey what are some other options to do
what you feel called to do but also
allow us to thrive financially because
it's there
it's definitely there yep
absolutely it can just be timing it can
be process it can be structure
and you still fulfill the calling
within the gut within a little bit of
different guidelines instead of an all
or nothing thing but for today you're
there so here's how we're going to help
you hang on kelly's going to help you
sign up we're going to walk with you on
this and want to see how god plays his
hand